first a new bombshell poll published
today shows that nearly half of the
king's Realms would vote to become
republics if they had the chance
Caribbean countries cite Colonial ties
as the reason for wanting to part with
the monarchy and pretty disturbingly for
King Charles 10 of the 14 countries
bowled so they backed the sussexes say
Megan's treatment exposes racist views
it's ignited debated about whether King
Charles should apologize for Britain's
past sins maybe even pay reparations
would that make any difference would it
just fuel the fire of republicanism well
he will be now to debate this is the
form of Royal Butler to Princess Diana
Paul Burrell the activist and organizer
of black lives matter protest Iman ayton
and the historian and Royal author Dr
Tessa Dunlop well this will be a quiet
debate won't you
well you brought your earplugs Paul
I won't get a look in let me start with
you I've got a problem with this
constant looking back in history feeling
guilty of the stuff that none of us in
this year era actually did and then
having to say sorry for everything that
we didn't do and even now apparently
having to pay people today the stuff
that happened to their ancestors many
generations before I don't really get
what that achieves we should learn from
lessons of the past
um we can't change anything
um and we should move forward but the
Queen's greatest achievement his
mother's greatest achievement was the
Commonwealth of countries she was very
proud of that I think if she could beam
her down now she would say my
Commonwealth that should survive intact
into the king's Reign so he should do
whatever he can now bear in mind I've
known this man for a very long time he
has a voice and what and he he will say
what he here's the real problem he's got
there's another voice yapping away yes
about racism two voices his son Harry
yes and Harry's wife Megan who for three
years have branded the royal family a
bunch of callous racist that is now
turning up in these holes because I'm
understandably frankly yes black people
in the Commonwealth around the world are
going whoa really they're racist these
people and yet they haven't produced a
shred of evidence for any of it you and
I know the royal family are not racist
and you and I know that they press the
races button on the Oprah Winfrey Show
yeah and they never apologize to the
queen never she went to her grave
thinking there was a racist in the royal
family they said what happened we never
didn't say that the president be to say
it was racism why don't you correct it
Harry why didn't you tell you well we
know why because it made them it made
them they weaponized racism and mental
health to make themselves extremely rich
I totally all right come on this is my
problem this has always been my problem
with this racism narrative that these
two have spun without any evidence is
that people around the world
particularly people of color they
believe it and why wouldn't they believe
it they're hearing the first person who
wasn't a white Royal bride say their
race is these people so then the damage
is is palpable is tangible and it will
lead I think if we're not careful to a
load of these countries becoming
republics and the beginning of the end
of the monarchy
thank you thank you
all right no problem so first and
foremost my feelings on the royal family
and racism are not predicated on Harry
and Megan's willingness to identify
that's the difference between me and you
we are talking about a country that was
built off of racism and we are referring
to the oldest institution in this
country that started at all so that's
the first thing in terms of why black
people and many others feel the way that
we do well the monarchy is a symbol of
white supremacy okay white supremacy
that is the reason let me why does it
make any difference if King Charles says
sorry or why does it if he pays money
what difference does that make
okay so record combat racism no it
actually does so let me guys we've got a
racist bone in his body he's done more
for racism than any public figure in the
country why should he be paying for the
sins of people hundreds of years ago
okay so can I finish yes thank you very
much so
the monarchy is a symbol of white
supremacy which is what black people
have had to contend with for the last
400 years notwithstanding the fact that
Elizabeth or every king and queen from
Elizabeth I think the last Lady Queen
was a model of white supremacist finish
let me finish my point you just ask me
several questions let me finish I'll
answer the question right I'm getting
there so just finished okay so if
every king queen from Elizabeth the
first one in the fourth has supported
and profited off of slavery so it this
is about the fact that this country was
built off of racism and that is that
this country also lives
because I haven't even finished my point
you can't just meet his statements about
our royal family not expect me to jump
in keep interrupting can I finish this
country also led the world out of
slavery okay so can I finish my point a
long time ago can I finish my point
please yes perfect please finish it I
will no problem just be patient so every
single king and queen from Elizabeth
first willing the fourth over 270
interested supported the enslavement of
Africans and profited as a result so it
doesn't it and this country yes hold on
a second it doesn't take a genius to
figure out that this country was built
off of racism and it stems from white
supremacy all of which is directly
attributed to the crowns they've
influence let me finish
you keep interrupting answer my
questions let's have a conversation
answer my question
hey guys I spoke about slavery let me
ask someone I asked
for what happened centuries ago okay
they're all paying money for it okay so
what you're talking about is slavery I'm
not talking about slavery so if you can
be traced back to your the Greek slave
trade to be specific in 400 BC then the
Roman Empire and then we get to the
Muslim conquest of seven centuries
what are you talking about right so
we're not talking about slavery comes in
many years there is a lot of slavery
around today but I told you what I'm
talking about talking about colonialism
neon colorism racism disparities in the
racist system of Oppression exploitation
of black people and white supremacists
which are bringing me banded under the
ground so you've got to do with King
Charles I am telling you why he needs to
apologize
what did he do I'm telling you
colonialism neocolonialism the spices in
a racist system and white supremacist
attitudes that is the legacies of the
crown slavery
I understand let me finally get my point
across Lord
across but here's my point my
Counterpoint to you what's any of that
got to do with King
who actually has been I think one of the
great standard bearers in Royal history
for actually promoting racial inequality
and tackling racial Injustice you want
him to be issuing groveling apologies
for people hundreds of years ago and you
want him to pay money okay so I think
black people would be far more inclined
to get over it if it wasn't for the fact
that the legacies of the crown slavery
and colonism still remain which includes
racism racial disparities and the racist
global system of Oppression and
exploitation of black people oh you're
not answering my question but you don't
want to accept it
as as a result of expectation of black
people and you also have that speak now
hold on you haven't even let me finish
this no problem no problem you've done
nine tenths of the talk no no you didn't
let them
you've heard the debate I think you're
both wrong actually on the one hand we
celebrate and you certainly do peers the
idea of monarchy is continuity yeah
going way back when I mean I read an
article this week that traced the
anointing oils to the Old Testament and
King Solomon you can't pick and choose
which bits of that continuous historic
line you like yes I can well how was
that um
and I would counter to you where we have
the face of history and the and the
physical form of history in our royal
family when for example France the
Republic outlawed slavery much later and
in The Civil Wars in America that's what
it took in America
you did all the Talking I see your
hypocrisy right now
what we're doing here is We're
translating an individual family with
institutions of State you can't expect a
king to apologize he doesn't have that
power he would have to be told to
Apologize by the government because it's
an institution
you keep talking about slavery let's be
clear about slavery yes you did end
slavery you've made that point and
you've made that point so let me address
it you did end slavery and there was a
clause in the contract that said for
example that Jamaicans had to work up to
45 hours a week for the following four
years while she simultaneously paid off
the slave owners and left the enslaved
in their countries to watch and then he
transitioned to colonialism well slavery
still continued and then he transitioned
to the Commonwealth I agree where you'll
continue to assert your dominance expect
people and do it in a fight I agreement
[Music]
time out the biggest problem with
slavery right now is there are between
seven to ten million slaves in India
last time I looked that is not as a
result of white supremacy causing modern
day slavery I would rather we expend all
our energy on current slavery issues
than going back in the past as we now do
we now go back in the past for
everything wallowing in self-guilt about
stuff that nothing to do with us
legacies
legacies of the crown saving colonialism
you ignored that's convenience this is
negative this isn't negative going back
how far do you want to go back 400 years
okay I told you that so do you think the
Vikings should be paying me money for
what they did to me so you're talking
about slavery I am not I would explain
what's all my favorite I'm talking about
colonialism
that's still content stop shouting
you're not listening to what I said
you're not listening should the Vikings
and the Romans also through their modern
day ancestors be be paying me
reparations for what they did to my
family so I'm not talking about slavery
I'm talking about colonialism it's not
slavery you're not listening to me yes I
am the Vikings and Romans didn't make it
slaves no yes you're talking about the
Roman Empire which included no I'm
talking about the Romans and the Vikings
coming over here and causing a
measurable harm to my ancestors
in one sentence one sentence Iman Iman
in one sentence go ahead what do you
want in one sentence
but I want money from the Vikings and
the Romans
no but the Commonwealth do is a Force
for good yes foreign
work for each other it's a family a
community of families that help each
other that's why it was formed and no
you benefit more that's why it's formed
no we don't benefit they benefit as well
they do benefit of course you do Paul
yes they do yes I'm not saying that they
don't what I'm saying is that we benefit
how much money do you want from me
that's what I keep talking about how
much money do you want from the national
Commission on reparation said that
Jamaica for example is is how much do
you want from me how much do you want
from me top up my feelings and not from
you I'm not this isn't about me we've
all got a chip in right so yeah
how much money could I give you for
something that had nothing to do with me
right how much money could I give you to
make legacies to make racism better
nothing we're talking about the legacies
of the clown saving planes racism I
don't know why you've come on deciding
to speak like a robot today it's not
it's not really working listen because
you don't listen that's why that nor
just talking to me like that doesn't
work okay well how about this I will
happily listening if you could convince
me that it will change racism one iota
in this country I will pay you a check
for the damage inevitably that was done
by my relatives when they weren't being
attacked by Vikings and Romans I I will
pay you reparations if I think you have
any argument for why I should and you
know what there isn't one can I give
yours that's it that's the point guys
thank you all very much indeed